I'm a customer engineer at Google Cloud
today I'm going to talk about VPC design
patterns that Google Cloud customers can
leverage one of the early design
decisions customers make on Google cloud
is related to the VPC Network
customers can have unique set of network
requirements but I will cover a few of
the common VPC design patterns with that
in mind let's get started a quick
refresher on VPC Concepts
vpcs are Global which means vpcs can
span across multiple regions subnets are
Regional and we have a shared VPC that
can be shared across multiple projects
within your Google Cloud organization
shared VPC is a core component of our
today's discussion together these
features of Google Cloud VPC helps
customers design simple yet secure
architectures
now let's review what is a shared VPC at
a high level you have one host project
and multiple service projects host
project is where you would create the
VPC and the subnets service projects are
then attached to the host project you
can share a subnet with one or multiple
service projects IIM users in a service
project with select IIM roles such as
compute admin project owner among others
will be given Network user permissions
to the shared subnets in the host
project this allows the IM users in the
service project to create resources in
the shared subnet a shared VPC allows
customers to centrally manage firewall
rules submit Creations connections
between on-prem and VPC rotting rules
among many other network operations
let's start with a simple design let's
create two separate networks one for
production and one for non-production
both of which can have subnets in
multiple regions these subnets are then
shared with multiple service projects
where applications will eventually be
hosted as a best practice we recommend
customers to create multiple service
projects for production and
non-production workloads naturally you
will take the development version of
your application and deploy it in the
non-production supplement and the
production version of your application
in the production subnet this design
gives you isolation between production
and non-production networks while giving
your network teams the ability to manage
network operations such as Fireball rule
management routing tables using single
Google Cloud project
how about connectivity to on-prem or
other clouds for that we can leverage
Google managed hivpn or Cloud
interconnect a VPN provides encrypted
ipsec VPN allows all the internet Cloud
interconnect offers private connectivity
between customers Data Center and Google
Cloud VPC when designed for high
availability your architecture would
look something like this you would have
two VPN tunnels or two interconnect
vlans per region from on-prem to each
one of these vpcs
however some customers like to
consolidate their VPN connections or
Cloud interconnect view lines and be
able to share them with more than just
one VPC especially when the Nintendo
scale Beyond just two vpcs so how do we
do that Hub and spoke model
building on what we already have let's
add a hub VPC to our core Network
project The Hub VPC can be connected to
the spokes via VPC peering or Google
managed hivpn how about the connectivity
from on-prem how many connections do we
need now if you recollect in our
previous design we had four connections
to connect two vpcs
since we now have a hub VPC we can share
the on-prem connectivity to the spokes
via the Hub VPC
some customers might want to create
network segregation between certain
workloads which means they might create
additional spoke vpcs for connectivity
to on-prem though all the spoke vpcs
will share the existing connection via
the Hub VPC Hub and spoke design lets
customers consolidate their hybrid
connections while allowing them to scale
spoke vpcs
some customers have common tools such as
active directory centralized logging
systems development tools that are used
across production and non-production
subnets these tools need to be accessed
from both production and non-production
vpcs so where do we deploy these tools
let's take a look
one way to architect this is to share a
subnet from The Hub VPC with a shared
services project tools deployed in this
project can be accessed from all the
spoke vpcs and the on-prem network
let's talk about Google managed services
such as Cloud SQL memory store among
others these Services leverage VPC
peering to provide private IP
connectivity this model is referred to
as private service access but VPC
peering is non-transitive so how does
this affect our design let's take a look
consider this use case in a hub and
spoke model what if direct access is
required from on-prem to Cloud SQL or
other Google managed services that use
private service access since these
services use VPC peeling to connect to
the respective shared VPC if there was
another VPC bearing between the Hub and
the spokes it would make the connection
transitive so on-prem would not be able
to reach these services
how do we design for this use case
one pattern is to use Google managed
hivpn between the Hub and this box this
will allow the on-prem systems to reach
Google managed services that use private
service access via the Hub VPC
with that our design would look
something like this
now we can extend the same design to
support multi-region deployments
in the case of multi-region deployments
typically customers have data center in
multiple regions
so they would create multiple Cloud
interconnect vlans or havpn connections
to the respective Google Cloud region
put it all together this is how a
multi-region hub and spoke VPC design
could look like
thank you for watching